nos côtes a pris tout cela moi du coup
je veux prendre celui là la rentrée
scolaire
timéo et ilian bon là passez chez eux à
neuf et six ans les deux garçons ne
remettront pas les pieds à l'école
voulait bien retourner à l'école pour
retrouver les copains puis aussi que la
maîtresse me manque mais je suis un peu
l'accord avec ma maman
pour en rester à la maison pour leur à
sa maman ce retour à l'école était
prématuré voire irresponsable pour elle
pas question de mettre la santé de ces
enfants en danger
l'école se poursuivra ici à la maison
une fois deux fois trois mois déjà le
virus m'angoisse pas mal si j'ai le
choix de ne pas les mettre en contact
avec les enseignants les copains copines
je préfère les garder à la maison et
surtout voilà je travaille pas donc je
peux les garder et il est là le départ
allez moi je prends la voiture de luxe
vient motif de lille camille est elle
aussi déterminée en l'absence de
certitude scientifique clair sur
l'impact du kobe 19 auprès des enfants
cette mère de famille n'en verra pas les
siens à l'école pour moi tous les
enfants qui vont y retourner c'est très
triste et dur à dire mais c'est un petit
peu les cobayes
ils vont retourner à l'école on verra
peut-être dans trois semaines que
finalement il y en a qui vont revenir
avec le virus à la maison pas forcément
eu mais leurs parents ou voilà comme
camille elle aura de nombreux parents
ont fait ce choix dicté par la crainte
sanitaire le retour à l'école c'est
surtout un retour au niveau du lien
social mais pas du tout au niveau des
apprentissages
donc s'ils ont la possibilité de garder
leurs enfants à la maison
ils le font pour être sécurisée selon la
fcpe 70% des parents ne souhaiterait pas
remettre leurs enfants à l'école